metroid dredd metroid is back baby with
a new metroid installment no weird
offshoot metroid games that aren't
really metroid games come on no metroid
dread is legit metroid 5 i've been
addicted to it been playing it non-stop
and now you all get to hear me talk
about my addiction
so let's do it
[Music]
so metroid drives not only the newest
installment of metroid it's the latest
chronologically speaking it's the newest
adventure you know like oh what happened
after metroid fusion now we know metroid
dread and you really do feel like they
knew it's been a while and so they gotta
they gotta jam pack this game with
enough content to make it feel like oh
that was worth it and they did i mean
you have what you expect from a metroid
game you know you have samus samus of
course loses all the powers all the
abilities all the power-ups all the
missiles so now you gotta go out there
and find abilities find new abilities
regain abilities that you've lost all in
the name of unlocking other areas that
you get to you know it's metroidvania
operative word metroidvania it really is
the godfather of the format or godmother
that is and when this was announced i
was super pumped super hyped because 2d
metroid was my first metroid love you
know so whenever there's a 2d metroid i
get more excited not that metroid prime
4 i'm not excited for because we all are
when that happens in 2037 but there was
a part of me that was like in metroid
dread am i going to miss the sprites am
i going to look at the camera here and
say
axiom verge did it better axiom verge is
great but no i i didn't miss the
surprise i don't feel the need to say
that i thought everything in this game
worked very well to maintain that
metroid
atmosphere and tone metroid's always had
sci-fi horror elements you know metroid
always reminded me of aliens then
metroid fusion reminded me of the thing
it's the thing in space this maintains
the elements of that also a little bit
of terminator in this one because you
have those emmi bastards coming at you
which add another level add another
layer of depth to this game there are
these sentinel robots you have no way of
defeating you just have to avoid them
definitely does give you that fight or
flight nothing quite as personal as a
parasite mimicking you but you know
still gives you that fear in fight or
flight and i loved it man like when you
get into that zone there were so many
times i was like i don't want to do this
i don't want to go back through there
just tiptoe and like please don't see me
[ __ ] i actually really enjoyed
them the novelty starts to wear off when
they start getting cheap that is to say
they start acting like lou kang from
mortal kombat but they're like huh
where's samus samus is invisible i have
no idea maybe she's there how how did
you know that i was being perfectly qui
how did frustrating moments like that
aside i really did enjoy them like i
said not only does it add another layer
but it also
lets you know where the new zone is
because this game is enormous and it
doesn't coddle you either you know with
metroid fusion metroid zero emission
some of the other metroids it was like
oh hey you want to know where to go next
here take me by the hand that is where
you go next now you know this game's
like biff it's like you want to know
where to go next
figure it out
you're like okay
dude i'm
not as young as i used to be so i'd love
to say i was able just to be like oh i
know where that room was let me go right
back there with this new ability i have
that i know goes right there it's for
that room i saw boom no i was like i
remember the room
let me look at the map where it oh god
well here we go time to start tracking
is it a tough metroid game yeah and
compared to other metroid games it's
actually one of the tougher games i'm
not talking like tough
like the original metroid you could say
the original metroid is the toughest
metroid game because
no map i mean that does add to the
difficulty right there also though i
feel like the regular enemies in the
original metroid they were just tougher
this game has tough enemies but not
normias enemies you run across any
normal enemies you're probably going to
wipe them out this game has some game
mechanics that rolled over from metroid
samus returns like the counter i love
the fact that you have that counter
attack i loved it in samus returns i
love it here i love the fact that they
didn't lose that that was a great
addition i love it when a game's like
yeah you can counter most anything you
gotta know when gotta know the timing so
you might die the first time you run
across a normal enemy because you maybe
you try to counter them you don't know
their movements yet you don't know when
to counter them some of them do the
thing like here i ca i fooled you bam
you know it's basic counter-mechanic
enemies they're gonna do that kind of
stuff but if you do land that counter
and kill the enemy on the counter you
get so much life back i mean you could
be beeping you know you have such little
life is doing the beep beep thing you
counter kill you get so much life you're
back in the game it's like it never
happened most of the deaths that will
happen to you in this game will come
from the bosses and i [ __ ] you not on
that one like most bosses hit for a
couple of energy tanks per hit you know
they hit for a couple hundred again when
you start getting the counters down you
start getting their movements down trial
and error you're gonna die by bosses but
when you figure out how and when to
counter them you get some life back so
that helps but most of the time if you
do die by a boss he hits you for so much
you're not even going to hear the beep
you're not even going to hear the
warning sign of like oh you're low on
life and the emm ice they'll kill you
too because they're dicks
metroidvania baby it's what it is i mean
the boss is though hard i'm not going to
sit there and be like yeah it's
blasphemous hard because it never was i
mean i suppose the bosses are hard when
compared to other 2d metroid bosses you
know you look at craig from super
metroid you beat his ass in like two
seconds in that game the bosses in here
are a little more difficult than that i
do love the fact that this game embraces
those secret ways to kill bosses i've
already seen online on youtube these
ways like you know you charge up your
run and then you run into a buzz i
actually did that on one of the bosses
don't know if that was how i was
supposed to kill that boss totally
throws back to metroid 2 return of samus
on game boy where the metroid queen you
can turn into the ball let the queen eat
you and just load her up with bombs in
her stomach and blow her to hell from
the inside or letting the underwater
boss and super metroid grab you and then
using the grapple beam on the
electricity to fry his ass that was a
really cool secret easter egg way to
kill the boss i just i always
appreciated that and i appreciate the
fact that this game does carry that
torch it was fun i love the fact that
samus has a slide also she has a slide
to get under little narrow passages
which means you don't need the morph
ball to do all of those moments it's
good at optimizing i feel like there are
a lot of abilities in this game too
abilities that you recognize from other
metroid games some abilities are new
here that mixed with the gameplay format
story and general mechanics that i'm
trying to be vague about metroid dread
works as a throwback and love letter to
previous metroid games that we've all
loved but also most definitely lands as
a sequel to metroid fusion which it also
needed to be little thoughts that i have
about the game like wish they'd done
that just they're little things like
with the analog stick i mean first of
all i've never felt i've had good
control using an analog stick in a
metroid game i much prefer the d-pad in
a game like this but this does force you
to do the analog stick and a couple of
times it screwed me what can i say but i
get why with the aiming and whatnot it's
just it's a thought i have i will say i
don't like how they condense the
missiles before in metroid you had
different missiles and they did
different things with varying degrees of
power in metroid dread you have missiles
and then you get super missiles and you
don't have missiles anymore which the
implication is well now the super
missiles are a lot stronger but since
you don't have regular missiles and
enemies get more difficult it just feels
like you have missiles just called
something else yeah sure i got ice
missiles but i felt like i lost my super
missiles by implication i think the game
is telling me yeah but ice missiles are
as powerful as super missiles they never
felt that way just felt like i lost my
super missile i prefer metroid where you
can choose the different missiles
depending on the situation and
circumstance and whatever power you need
but that's probably my biggest gripe
about the game is how they handled the
missiles but in the end metroid dread i
thought it was a home run it was
fantastic it was a great metroid 5.
metroid 5 i've waited for for 19 years
and it was worth the wait and it shows
that they really wanted you to feel like
it was worth the wait metroid's a
franchise i always feel like nintendo
sleeps on but it's like this is one of
the greatest franchises they have
example in this world of so many
collections for the switch you got
castlevania collections contra
collections uh more castlevania
collections a metroid collection for the
switch
that would be amazing and i feel like a
lot of people would pick that up have
the original metroid metroid 2 return of
samus for game boy super metroid metroid
fusion metroid zero mission and in a
perfect world port samus returns the 3ds
game to the switch takes some doing but
you know it's possible i feel like in
situations like that these companies are
always like work
or nintendo if you want to play nice
am2r was a labor of love cut a check for
dr m64 get that on there too but if we
never see that metroid collection that i
think they most certainly definitely
absolutely should do on the switch
metroid dread it's a great game if
you're a metroid fan you've been looking
for a new side-scroller metroid odds are
you've already played this metroid dread
was a great metroidvania adventure in an
interesting world with very well-crafted
level design great weapons but most of
all if you're going to hit me in the
metroid feels it had great tone with a
solid eerie soundtrack that really hit
that home and metroid dread is
awesome tacular
[Music]
also getting some of these secrets some
of these hidden missiles hidden energy
tanks man the worst is when you see it
like you know what you have to do
but gaining the muscle memory to pull it
off very different things you'll run
into that on more than a few occasions
in here and in that it's getting some of
the items in here is the toughest i've
ever seen in a 2d metroid game right so
metroid dread have you played it what
did you think about it what's your
favorite metroid game for me it's always
going to be super metroid it just
it just always well heart nostalgia part
execution but the atmosphere and tone in
that game is just top notch they make a
metroid movie
that's the tone i'd love to see on
screen whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you